[Musique]
j'ai demandé au chroniqueur de me dire
un petit peu non pas oui alors ils
peuvent nous dire comment ils vont
passer leurs vacances parce que vous
aimez bien connaître leur vie mais de
nous ramener un petit souvenir de
vacances comme ça sur le tour de table
donc déjà ou est-ce que vous allez
passer vous sauf si c'est un discret non
ce n'est pas un secret je vous dit tout
je vais partir chez nous il y avait des
vues de l'agent bretons se sentant vous
avez remarqué que hier c'était pareil
c'est pile comme mon émission des
marques isis à l'heure
oui alors les vacances et bien en
vacances je vais partir au brésil à
partir c'est pas trop la période du
carnaval bébé a presque mais voyez ça
c'est typiquement le mec en boîte qui
veut faire le malin je prends au brésil
à le carnaval et non c'est pas cette
période là où nous avions ramené une
petite photo oui je vous ai rapporté une
petite photo parce que je fais c'est hot
bas piqué je ne sais pas je vous laisse
juge
donc ça c'est ce que vous faites quand
vous allez en vacances mais c'est
beaucoup de sport quand je suis en
vacances j'aime bien les trucs très
sportif très voilà on aime bien
l'abolition me suffit et à leur rêve là
là ne bougez pas je vois déjà le truc
regardes tu postale hier sur la cuisse
comme ça s'est un peu fait une petite up
du pique nique
contrairement à l'émission late efforts
on n'a pas eu à mettre une étoile sur
les faits ces rongeurs si c'était comme
un mythe bardot on n'était pas loin d'un
taux à l'éphédrine est un fait comment
vous tenez j'ai fait une pause qui fait
style un peu mais c'est quoi cette vidéo
est aujourd'hui en fait une pause de
yoga mais en fait c'est un truc que tout
le monde peut faire c'est à dire que le
théâtre c'est assez impressionnant
visuellement en réalité vous soumettant
poirier oublier un peu les jambes tout
le monde peut le faire directement à le
faire non mais les bras et de l'est
attendez-vous isabelle morini-bosc
essaie de le faire on l'a salué sortir
de l'hôpital normal voire début octobre
maxime guérite avec le sénat
en train de gagner des points à
l'applaudimètre le lien ce mode il va
pas nous détruire prix progressent il
progresse comment ça va presque bien
suis content d'être parmi vous il ya
toujours une bonne ambiance
ok merci de ce continent
nous avons mené une photo oui alors je
n'ai envoyé deux je ne sais pas laquelle
a été sélectionnée c'était un copain
avec mes frères c'est votre frère très
bien victo manqué derrière et trouver
décembre justement dans le sud pour pour
aider justement mon frère et ma mère qui
viennent d'ouvrir leur bar à jus 100 %
bio 100% vegan hobo provence vous avez
qu à faire de la pub si vous n'êtes pas
un cousin qui vend des voitures on peut
justement alors il est situé à elles
vont me déchu votre meilleur ami
ouvriront produit de quoi des smoothies
à évaluer pl du vainqueur et autres
pâtisseries vraiment sans enjeu à
l'intérieur mais hyper gourmande à voilà
donc j'ai fait un peu le serveur les
terres c'est regarder qui est de retour
juste
en soin bio bien sûr vous avez fait une
couleur ou s'il était qu'est ce qui
s'est passé mais bon c'est une mauvaise
blague avec cyril voilà donc c'est
toujours la bloque oui regardez surtout
si je gardais en fait j'ai appris que
c'était bon si j'avais ça pour six mois
quoi donc
david guetta du pauvre david ghetto a
alors on va regarder au mrc ça nous fait
plaisir en tout cas de voir que vous
êtes vous retrouvé julien alors la photo
de françois viot vous pouvez la décrire
auparavant ah ben je suis en lorraine
les écouter we all orange et moi j'ai
pas les moyens de maxime c'est vrai mais
bon bonne photo c'est que j'aurais pu
vous dire on leur a demandé de faire une
photo un peu délire prononcé des vraies
photos vraiment ça
[Applaudissements]
ne rigolez pas parce que c'est moi c'est
un conte natation là je vais pas voter
pour un musée qui vous fait ça non non
non c'est un vrai conte de natation j'ai
la phobie de l'eau et voilà que c'est
quelqu'un qui vient chez vous d'un
maître nageur voilà mais bon j'ai pas
les moyens de maxime moi j'ai pas la
piscine vient pas donner
retrouvez moi quand même ses maîtres
nageurs qui se fout complètement de sa
gueule en lui faisant croire à qui va
lui mais vous faites vraiment ça l'était
il faut que je m'habitue à louer quand
même c'est pas normal d'avoir cette
phobie de l'eau depuis que d'outils
c'est vrai que les sims en rentrant
clairement dedans bon tu peux tu ne
m'aimes tu dois y est dedans coire en
revanche je savais pas un coin de
plongeon la berthauderie plongeon voilà
on ne me prenez pas pour plus bêtes que
gilles verdez et là il est toujours
c'est un peu un peu je n'ai pas honte à
le dire le pilier sur lequel je m'appuie
pour essayer de bien mener la l'émission
comment ça va manger très bien vous avez
pris une photo oui jamais une photo de
vacances
oui c'est une photo entre c'est très
important pour moi c'est entre la baule
et saint nazaire et je passe
régulièrement des vacances là bas et
quand je pars en vacances il faut que je
trouve des pierres donc là je suis sur
ma pierre donc j'ai ma pierre laba
heureux qu'est ce qu'il y avait sur la
pierre pour bouffer
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vous allez sur une pierre il ya une
succession de cette pierre et chaque
matin je vais leur parler
tristesse quand qu'est ce qu'on leur dit
aux pierres à ça dépend desquels l'année
dernière la dernière alors il y avait
une pierre qui s'appelait jean luc je
crois que c'est celle là la côte est
parce que je lui parlais de jeu disait
jean luc fougasse my edge se passe bien
et tout ça je parle aux gens j'ai
retrouvera jean luc c'est la pierre quoi
alors là vous avez la photo mais dix
minutes après vous avez une autre photo
avec l'ambulance qui viennent chercher
qu'il le ramène au centre ses vacances
tout est là pendant qu'il fait ça il
n'est pas au bistrot comment ça va ma
belle on nous avons magali keita
la dynastie des bardas on en a connu des
bardas dans le métier alors c'est vrai
qu'on ne peut que moi j'ai envoyé 15
photos c'est vrai mais alors là qu'il a
trouvé ses choix avec des firmes et non
celui des grimaces d'accord c'est un
symbole commun ça permet de voir un peu
la langue alors on fait souvent
exactement le trouble donc nous on
s'amuse on fait la fota sur les petites
taches blanches je ne sais pas ce que
c'est mais tout est parfait car celui-ci
n'était plus étudiée
capucine cet après midi vous avait
simulé j'ai appris ça là j'ai simulé
quoi on n'a pas fait une simulation pour
le jeu ah oui bah oui mais je pense à
autre chose et pour ça oui c'est la
principale peu de labeur je crois que
malheureusement on est obligés d
expliquer ces bons vient pas alors alors
moi j'en ai une photo justement mais
pour me rappeler un petit peu de bon
temps que du bon temps que j'ai passé en
famille à l'époque où on était tous
ensemble avec mes soeurs avec mes
parents voilà c'est juste que à l'époque
où j'avais un look de merde voilà
parce que j'étais en cris de l'ado je me
cherchais un peu et c'est un mobile-home
derrière ouais on partait au camping à
saint tropez quand on était plus jeunes
les verts viennent évolué du mobile home
à l'elysée et évidemment sylvain gamma
et le dernier c'est parce que il y à dos
et il y à un dos on a dû à la dernière
minute quand il nous a envoyé sa photo
l'emmener dans un banc de montage car
monsieur prendre des photos sur un
bateau jusque là ça va mais je prends
c'est moi expliqué non mais c'est une
photo qu'on a pris sur tournage de deux
caches island et la photo en elle même
n'est pas intéressante du taux sauf que
après relecture de la photo visiblement
j'avais laissé échapper quelque chose de
mon slip
à y regarder alors vous
le smiley alors c'est pas c'est pas sa
vraie télé comme ça à cet instant il est
qu on a rajouté
oui mais effectivement à elle part alors
là nous ne montrons pas parce que c'est
pas l'esprit de l'émission d'ordre ce
sont des choses maintenant on est passé
à totalement autre chose c'est un
nouveau thé pmp malgré tout vous avez
envie de la montrer pour ceux qui
veulent sur votre compte twitter
si ça vous fait plaisir oui oui oui ou
merci possible un peu tôt mais attention
ce tiers précise également que le smiley
beaucoup plus gros que coca ce que les
audiences du jour j'en ai pour inga
léopard non je montre pas ça moi j'ai un
peu de pudeur